this was just a scam for her to get the
seven million dollars in the divorce
settlement that she said she gave to the
aclu she swore she gave to the aclu and
the children's hospital of los angeles
and she pocketed
instead mr depp mr brosti mr corrino
mr wiggum and the inevitable mr doherty
of the aclu which lent its once
respected name
to miss heard's defamation
so while miss heard may have avoided any
direct mention of mr depp's name there
is extensive testimony and evidence in
the record showing that the implication
of her op-ed could not be more clear i.e
that mr depp abused ms hur during the
course of their marriage
under virginia law quote it is not
necessary that the defamatory charge be
in direct terms but it may be made
indirectly and it matters not how artful
or disguised the modes in which the
meaning is concealed if it is in fact
defamatory
citing car while we can argue as to how
artful it was
but the implication was very clear as
the court has previously
ruled or
not law of the case but as the court has
uh persuasively written in its opinion
letter
let's move to the falsity of ms hurt's
ever evolving and ever escalating change
of ipv and sexual assault
mr depp's sworn denial is all he needs
to survive a motion to strike but
there's a lot more than that your honor
and i'll try to be brief
three police officers actually four but
the three who testified already officer
science hadden and gatlin testified
unequivocally that ms heard did not have
a mark on her on the evening of may 21
2016. i can tell you she's not the
abuser and if the case moves forward she
and her witnesses will put on even more
evidence of the physical abuse she
suffered at the hands of mr deb but
that's not the basis for our emotion
right now your honor he he talks about
how mr depp uh had a sworn denial
um and that that should count he he we
read his testimony he claims he didn't
strike her
but again that's not the basis for our
emotion the basis for emotion is the
clear and undisputed evidence of
non-physical abuse by his definitions by
his standards by the standards of his
expert there is no dispute that mr depp
on abused amber and therefore if he did
it even one time
there is no dispute that even under
their theory of the case
the implication that they want the jury
to draw from the article which again i'm
not
arguing for the purposes of today
because under the legal standard i'm not
going to argue that i'm not going to
waste the court's time with that but
even under their standard
the undisputed evidence is that mr depp
did commit abuse against misheard and
therefore that those first two
statements were false
that's that's our argument on that as to
the headline it's funny mr chu
we played you know two or three hours of
an aclu deposition now he says well that
wasn't our witness it was his witness
your honor he just spent 10 minutes
talking about what mr doherty said
and mr doherty testified that the
washington post wrote the headline that
is the only evidence your honor i
understand he says well exhibit one has
her name on it exhibit one has her name
on it but the only evidence in this case
about who wrote that headline is mr
doherty's testimony it is undisputed
they could have put anyone else on they
could have called ms hurd for that
because that was not part of the
stipulation at the at the pre-trial
conference it was only the tweet that we
talked about your honor and they chose
not to do that now miss heard will
testify she didn't write that headline
so it wouldn't have helped them but that
they've had
three weeks to put on their case your
honor they've controlled the playing
field of evidence there is no dispute
that misheard did not write that
headline
no dispute simply saying well her name
is attached to it that can't overcome
the testimony of the aclu they call them
a co-conspirator of course mr depp chose
not to sue them um
but the testimony of terence doherty
that she didn't write that headline that
takes care of the sexual violence
headline your honor for this motion i've
taken the arguments of counsel when last
night i reviewed all of the evidence
that has been submitted in this matter
so as to the second and third alleged
defamatory statements um at the motion
strike at this juncture i view the
evidence in light most favorable to the
plaintiff and reasonable inferences from
the evidence to the plaintiff and if
there is a scintilla of evidence that a
reasonable juror could weigh then the
matter survives a motion to strike
in this matter there is evidence in the
case that a jury could weigh that the
statements were made by the defendant
that the statements were about the
plaintiff that the statement was
published that the statement is false
and the defendant made the statement
knowing it to be false or the defendant
made it so recklessly as to amount to a
willful disregard for the truth
the weight of that evidence is up to the
fact finder so the motion to strike is
denied as the statement two and three
the motion to strike as a statement one
i'm going to take under advisement
because um
if it's not a stipulation i'm not sure
what it is but there seems to be an
agreement that the tweet of misheard is
part of the plaintiff's evidence which
is not in evidence at this point so i
can't rule on that statement whether or
not it is just a tweet or if it's some
sort of republication or something i
don't know because i haven't seen it yet
so as to the motion to strike on on
statement one i'm going to take an
advisement because ruling out now it
would be premature because i just don't
have that evidence in the case okay
thank you very much ronnie all right